If there's one thing about me is that I'm a hopeless romantic.
So weddings always make me ball my eyes out.
Especially since my sister Daisy got married today.
We got everyone up at 4:00am
since we wanted to catch sunrise on the salt flats.
And it was the most magical thing.
The wedding was beautiful.
There was no phones allowed during the ceremony,
which made it so much more special.
Seeing all the Smith siblings together always makes me so happy.
I feel so grateful that I got to witness something so beautiful
and heavenly. Makes me wanna plan a whole vow renewal.
There's something so beautiful about choosing a life partner.